there were a handful of republicans who
voted for
impeachment in the house i think it's
important to read their names
so that we can remember those names john
catko of new york
adam kinzinger of illinois fred upton
jamie butler dan newhouse peter miger
anthony gonzalez tom rice and tom
valadao do you recognize any of those
names i don't either
they they just sound like some gop
backbenchers
worth remembering i guess when they're
up for re-election
obviously trump will be gone at that
point but the squishiness and the
disloyalty
and the ignorance of the law even just
on the
on the objective legal matters of the
impeachment
really makes one question their judgment
there is one name though that we can
recognize here that would be liz cheney
liz cheney daughter of dick cheney
liz cheney voted for impeachment
and liz cheney is technically in
leadership
so she's not you know the minority
leader the republican minority leader in
the house or anything like that she's
not
chief whip or anything like that she is
the chairman of the gop conference and
it is a very strange thing
that someone who is at least technically
in republican leadership in the house
would vote to impeach the republican
president
with no real legal basis the legal
charge here was that
trump incited a mob to attack the
capital we played the clip on the show
you might say that trump's actions in
the last month or two have been
imprudent unwise irresponsible reckless
okay
use whatever adjective you want they
haven't been illegal he did not
incite the mob to commit violence at the
capitol he explicitly said
be peaceful so whatever you want to say
about trump
it's a frivolous charge dan crenshaw
pointed that out
just a couple of days ago and yet liz
cheney voted for very strange to have
that kind of a person in gop leadership
really really don't have a ton of faith
in her judgment
and i don't have faith in the judgment
of gop leadership
if they're going to have a person like
that there i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you